eating that were divided in two parts so
number one and we work with you and
develop the sequence to sequence
learning and then that's the second part
I would I will place sequin to sequence
in a broader context or a lot of
exciting work in this area now so let's
multiply this by a an example so a week
ago I came back from vacation and my in
my inbox I have five hundred and eight
emails and reply emails and a lot of
emails I basically just require just yes
and no answer so let's try to see
whether we can do a system that can
automatically reply these emails to say
yes and no and for example so some of
the email would be you know from my my
friend on she said hi in the subject and
she said are you visiting Vietnam for
the New Year walk that would be her
content and then my probable reply would
be yes so you can gather another set
like this and then you know you have
some inputs content so less for now
let's ignore the the the on the author
of the email and the subject but let's
focus on the content so let's suppose
that you gather some email and some
input would be something like are you
visited in Vietnam for the New Year Kwok
and the answer will be yes and then the
another email would be are you hanging
out with us tonight
the answer is no because I'm quite busy
so the third email would be did you read
the coolness paper on breast net the
answer is yes because I liked it
now let's let's do a little bit of
processing we're basically in the in the
previous slide we have gear and comma
and then kwok and then question mark and
so on so let's let's do a little bit of
processing and then put the the comma a
space between gear and comma and then
Kwok and question mark and so on so this
step a lot of people call tokenization
and normalization so let's do that with
our emails now so and then the second
step I would do would be to do feature
representation so in this step what I'm
going to do is the following I'm going
to construct a 2,000 dimensional vector
2,000 represent the size of English
vocabulary and then I'm going to go
through email I'm going to count how
many times a particular word occur in my
email for example for example the world
are occur one in my email so I increase
the counter and then you occur one so I
increased another counter and s etc and
then I will reserve at the end a token
to reserve to just count all the words
that just our vocabulary okay and then
now you now use successful you if you do
this project a process you're going to
convert all of you or your email from
input to output pairs where the input
would be fixed line representation of
20,000 dimensional vector and output
would be either year or one okay any
questions so far okay good
okay so I will get so as you said
somebody in the audience that the order
of the words don't matter matter
and the answer is yes so I'm going to
get back to that issue later now so
that's x and y and now your job my job
now is to try to find some W search that
W time X can approximate Y Y is the
output right and Y here is yes and no so
because of this problem is has two
categories you can think of it as a
logistic regression problem now if
anybody follow the gray cs2 10:29 class
by andrew probably can formulate this
very quickly but in a very short you the
album comes as follow you kind of try to
come up with a vector for every email
your w is a two column matrix okay
the first column will find the
probability for the eat whether the
email have to be answer as yes second
column will be answered as no and then
you basically take the dot product
between w1 at the first column now Adam
is called the stochastic gwendy set so
you run for iteration one to like a
million you run for a long long time you
sample a random email X and then some
reply and then if the reply is yes then
you want to update your w1 and w2 such
that you increase the probability that
the answer is yes so you increase the
first probability now if your reply is
if the correct reply is no then you're
gonna update w1 and w2 so that you can
increase the probability of the is email
to be answered as you know
so the second probability okay so let's
call those a p1 and p2 now so because to
update I said to update the increase
what does that mean what that means is
that you find the gradient of the
partial gradient of the objective
function with respect to some parameter
so now you have to pick some alpha which
is the learning rate and then you say W
1 is equal to W 1 plus some alpha the
partial derivative of block of P 1 with
respect to D of W 1 ok
now I cheated a little bit here because
I used the log function it turns out
because the log function is a mono is a
monotonic increasing function so
increasing P 1 is equivalent to increase
in the log of P 1 ok and it usually with
this formulation stochastic gradient
descent works better any question so far
and then you can also update you know W
2 if the email is to be reply is yes and
you can you can have different way to
update and to if the reply is no so
what's a and then if you have a new
email coming in then you take X and then
then you control into the vector then
you compute the first probability ok W 1
time X divided by W exponential W 1 time
X plus exponential or W 2 time X and if
that probability is larger than 0.5 then
you say yes and if that probability is
less than 0.5 then you say no ok so
that's how you do prediction with this
now
now this there's a problem with this
representation is that there's some
information loss so somebody in the
audience just said that the order of the
words don't matter and that's that's
true now let's let's fix this problem by
using something called the recurrent
Network and I think a rigid soldier
already talked about recurrent networks
and some part of it yesterday and Andrei
as well now there the idea of a
recurrent Network is basically you have
also have fixed representation for your
input but it actually preserves some
sort of info ordering information and
the way that you compute the hidden
units the following
so the function hash of Euro is
basically hyperbolic hyperbolic tangent
of some some matrix you time the work
vector for the world are okay so Richard
also talk about what vectors yesterday
so you you can take what vectors coming
out of what to back or you can just
actually randomly initialize them if you
want to okay so let's suppose that
that's H of zero now H of one would be a
function of H zero and the vector for
you which is a times H of zero plus u
times V of vector u and then you can
keep going with that to see one of my
three three most complicated slides so
you are you should ask questions no
questions so everybody familiar with
recording that sir well
okay so to make predictions with this
but you you tack on the label at the
last step and then you say try to
predict why for me how do you do that
now here I I basically you you went the
way you did before and basically you
make update on the W matrix which is the
the classifier at the top like what I
said earlier now but you also have to
update all the relevant matrices which
is the matrix you the matrix a and some
work vectors right so this is basically
you have to compute the partial
derivative of the last function with
respect to those parameters now that's
going to be very complicated and usually
I when I do that I do that myself I get
that wrong but there's a lot of tools
out there that you can use which is you
can use auto auto differentiation in
tensor flow or you can call torch or you
can call piano to actually compute the
derivatives and once you have the
derivatives you can just make the update
right yeah yes so you the matrix you are
share so I'm going to go back to one
side so this matrix you I share all for
all vertical matrices right and the size
you have to determine ahead of time for
example the number of column would be
the size of the work vectors but the
number of rows must be like like a
thousand if you want or maybe 255 you
want so this is model selection and it
depends on whether you under fit in over
fitting to choose a bigger model or a
smaller model and your compute power so
that you can train a larger model a
smaller model
the matrix you yeah so the the work
vectors the world vectors the number of
work vectors that you use are the size
of vocabulary right which is so you
gonna tend to end up with 20,000 work
vectors right but the the size of so
that means you have 20,000 rows in
matrix U but the number of column you
can sorry the number of column is 20,000
but the number of row would be you have
to determine up just yourself okay any
other questions now okay so what's a big
picture so the big picture is I started
with bag-of-words representations and
then I talked about a and n as a new way
to represent variable size input that
can capture some sort of ordering
information then I'll talk about Auto
differentiation so that you can compute
the partial derivatives and these you
can find auto intensive flow or piano or
torch now then I talked about stochastic
when descent as a way to train the
neural networks and the question so far
okay you have a question oh that's also
depends on how big your your training
set and how big is your computer and so
on right but usually if you use an N and
if you used like a hidden state of a
hundred you should take like a couple
hours yeah but it depends largely
largely depends on you know size of
training data because you want to
iterate for all a lot of you sample a
lot of emails right you and you want
your algorithm to see as many emails as
possible right so okay so if you use
such algorithm to just say yes no and
just know then
you might end up losing a lot of friends
because because because we don't just
say yes no because we went to say when
for example my friend asked me are you
visiting Vietnam for the new year walk
then maybe the better answer would be
yes see you soon right that's not better
nicer way to approach this and then if
if my friends ask me are you hanging out
with us tonight
so instances say no I would say no I'm
too busy or did you read the coop ok
right so let's let's see how we're going
to fix this so so before I'm gonna tell
you the solution I would say this is the
this problem is drew it basically
requires you to map between variable
size input and some variable to some
variable size output right and if you
can do something like this then there's
a lot of applications because you can do
auto reply which is what we've been
working on so far but we can also work
on user to do translation just like
between English French you can do image
captioning so input would be an a fixed
like vector or representation coming
from conflict and then output would be
the cat sat on the mat right or you can
do summarization the input will be a
document and output would be some summer
summary of it or you can do two speech
transcription where you can have input
would be speech frames and output would
be words or you can do conversation so
basically the input would be the
conversation so far and the output could
be might reply or you can do cue night
etc etc so we can keep going on now so
how do we solve this problem so so this
is this is hard so let's check out what
Android capacity has to say about
recurrent networks okay so so Android
say that there's more than one way that
you can configure your network to do
things so we can do you could use your
network to map recurrent networks to map
one two
right so the at the bottom that's an
input the the green would be the hidden
state and the output would be the what
you want to predict now 1 1 2 1 is not
what we want right because we have many
too many so it's probably more like the
last two to the right right but we
arrived as the solution that I said in
the red box and the reason why it does
that's a better solution is because the
the the size of the input and the size
of output can vary a lot sometimes you
have smaller input but larger output but
sometimes you have larger input and
smaller output so if you do the one in
the red circle you can be very flexible
right if you do the one to the extreme
right then maybe the output has to be
smaller or at least the same with the
with the input right which what we are
that's what we don't want
so let's construct a solution that look
like that so okay so here's the solution
so the input would be something like hi
how are you right and then let's put a
special token unless let's say the token
is end and then you're going to predict
the first token which is M and then you
predict the second token fine and then
you predict the throat Oken thanks and
then you keep going on until you predict
the world end and then you stopped now I
want to mention that B in the previous
set of slides I was just talking about
yes and no and ingest no you have only
two choices okay now you have more than
two choices you have actually 20,000
choices and you can actually use the
algorithm that are the the logistic
regression and you can expand it to
cover that more than one more than two
choices you can have a lot of choices
okay and then the algorithm uses just
follow the same way now so dizzy
my first solution when I say walk - sick
- sick but it turns out it didn't work
very well and the reason why I didn't
work very well is the model never know
what it actually predicted in the in the
last step so it keep a keep going and
you keep synthesizing output but it
didn't know what it said it didn't know
what decision it committed in the
previous step so a better simpler
solution would look like this a better
solution is you back basically you feed
what the model predicts in the previous
step as input to the next step alright
so for example in this case I'm going to
take am I'm going to feed it in to the
next step so that I'm conduct completing
the dance in the second world which is
fine and etc so a lot of people call
this concept auto regressive so you you
take your you eat your own output and
make it as your input any questions so
far or whenever it produced end then
just stop there's a special token end
yeah
now okay so the so relevant architecture
here would be the end code people also
call the encoder as the what the
recurrent network in the input and the
decoder would be the recurrent network
in the output okay okay so how do you
train this so again so you basically you
run for a million steps you see all your
emails and then you say you sample and
for each iteration you sample an email X
and a reply why why would be you know
I'm fine thanks right and then the
sample random work YT in Y and then you
update the iron and encoder and decoder
parameters so that you can increase the
probability that Y of T is correct given
all what you seen before which is your
YT minus 1 YT minus 2 etc and also all
the axes right and then you have to
compute the partial derivatives to make
it work so the computing part partial
this is very difficult so again I
recommend you to use something like Auto
differentiation intensive flow or torch
or Tiano okay you have a question yeah
but the recurrent Network the number of
parameters didn't change because you
have U and V a UV and I are fixed right
okay so the question in the in the
audience is that there's um if the iron
and are different in four different
example and the answer is yes so the
number of steps and are different I have
a question there okay yeah I'm gonna get
to that in the next slide
yeah okay all right so the question is a
in practice how long would I go to for
the RN I would say if you usually stop
at like 400 steps or something like that
because outside of that it's going to be
too long to make the update and compute
it's very expensive to compute but you
can go more if you want to yeah I have a
question yeah
yeah yeah yeah so that's a problem so if
I'm going to talk about the prediction
next so let me go to the prediction and
then you can ask questions so okay so
how do you do prediction so this the
first algorithm that can we can you can
do is go greedy decoding okay in greedy
decoding is for any incoming email X I'm
going to find I'm going to predict the
first word okay and then you find the
most likely word and then you feed back
in and then you find the next most
likely word and then then you feed back
in and etc so if you keep going you keep
going until you see the world end and
then stop all it is exceed a certain
length you stop okay
now that's just do greedy okay so let's
let's do a little bit less greedy so it
turns out that so given X you can
predict more than one candidate so let's
say you can predict a candidate's let's
say three okay so you take three
candidates and then for each candidate
you're going to feed in the next step
and then you arrive at three so the next
step you're going to be have nine
candidates right and then you're going
to end up going that way so here's a
picture so given input X I'm going to
predict the first token there would be
hi yes and please and given every first
token like this I'm going to feed back
into the network and the network will
produce another three and etc so you're
going to end up with a lot of a lot of
candidates so how did you select the
best candidate well you can traverse
each beam and then you compute the John
probability at each step and then you
find the sequence I have the highest
probability to be the sequence of choice
what is your reply any question to see
the most complicated slide in my talk
oh yeah yes so the question is what do
you do with our vocabulary works now it
turns out in this algorithm what you do
is that for any word that is our
vocabulary you create a token call
unknown and you map everything to
unknown or anything that our vocal every
vocabulary to be unknown so it doesn't
seem very nicely but usually it works
well there's a bunch of algorithms to
address these issues for example they
break it into like characters and things
like that
and then it you could fix this problem
yeah yeah the cost function is that so I
go back one slide so the cost function
one more slide so the cost function is
that you sample a random were YT here
let's suppose that here I this is my
input sofa or an input and I'm sample YT
let's say T is equal to 2 so which means
the work fine okay I'm at the work fine
I want to increase the probability of
the model to predict whoa fine
so the every time the model will make a
lot of predictions some a lot of them
will be incorrect right so you have a
lot of probabilities
you have probability for the water and
the probably a and etc and then probably
for zzzzz right and you have a lot of
probabilities you want the probability
probabilities for the worst for the work
fine to be as high as possible you
increase the probability does that make
sense
or you condition on IIM so you condition
so when I'm at fine my input would be hi
how are you and and um okay that's
that's all I see and then I need to make
a prediction and I have to make that
prediction right right and you know if
I'm at the world thanks my input would
be hi how are you and I'm fine and I
gotta get my thanks for probability
right okay yeah I have a question here
oh I haven't thought about it yet so the
question is how do you personalize so
well one way to do it is basically embed
a user as a vector so let's suppose that
you have a lot of users and you embed a
user as a vector that's one way to do it
yeah I have a question here
yeah yeah so the question is that let's
suppose that my beam search is 10 then
you go to from 10 like a hundred and
then a thousand and suddenly it grows
very quickly right it go to rule a if
you if your sequence is long then you
end up with K to the N or something like
that well one way to do it is basically
you do truncate that beam search where
any any sequence with very low
probability you just pick it up you
don't use it anymore so you go so you
can do this you can do 3 9 and then you
ten to seven and then you go back up to
9 right and then you keep going so that
way you don't end up with a huge beam
and usually in practice using like a
beam size of three or ten would work
just fine and whoops wait yeah yeah I
have a question okay so for because it's
a 9n we don't have to Pat the input now
to be fast sometimes we have to Pat the
input because we want to make use make
sure that batch processing what's very
well so you'd be bad but we paired with
only like zero tokens
okay yeah so let's suppose that you have
a sequence of ten then you have a graph
of ten when you have a sequence a batch
of all twenty you haven't made a graph
for twenty and etc yeah that will make
the GPU very happy I have a question
that
oh so so you are you asking sort of so
my interpretation of your question is
how do you insert the world embedding
into the model is that correct our user
embed an old if you want to personalize
the thing then at the beginning you have
a vector and that's a vector for quoc
with a ID one two three four five and
then if is Peter then the vector would
be five six seven eight yeah yeah that's
one way to do it
yeah well there's more than one way you
can do it at the end or you can do it at
the beginning or you can insert a tab at
every prediction steps but my proposal
is just predict put it at the beginning
the simpler okay I have a question there
yeah you
yeah
that's a very good question the question
is what if the model details right if we
make a prediction and then that's a bad
prediction and your model never see and
then it keeps detailing and it will
pretty produce garbage yeah that's a
that's a good question so I'm going to
get to that so well so this is sly so
there's an algorithm for scheduled
sampling so in scheduled sampling what
you do is you you instead of feeding the
truth during training you can fee feet
what sample from the sub max so what
generated by the model and then feed in
as input so that the model understands
that if it produce something bad it
would suck actually can recover from it
right so that's that's one way to
address this issue is that make sense
yeah any question there's a question
here okay yeah yeah yeah so in this
algorithm yeah the question is how large
is the the size of the Dakota well my
answer is that try to be as large as
possible but it's going to be very slow
and in this algorithm what happens is
that you you use the same you use like
fixed length embedding for like to
represent the very very much the long
term dependency like a huge input right
and that's going to be a problem so I'm
going to come back to that issue with
the attention model in a second okay
any question okay here's a question
ah so does the model learn synonyms is
that a question or what's the question
oh I see well yeah it turns out that if
you learn it turns out that it mapped
good and if you visualize embedding the
good and fine and so on I'm not very
closely to the to the embedding space
but in the output there's we don't know
what else to do the other approach is
basically to train the world embeddings
using water vac and then try to ask the
model to regress to the world imbalance
right so that's one way to address this
issue we tried something like that did
not work very well so whatever we have
in here was pretty good okay I have to
keep going but like any way the
algorithm that you've seen so far turns
out actually answer some emails so if
you use the smart reply feature in inbox
it's already used this system in
production now for example in the indc
me email my colleague Ricardo got an
email from his friend saying that hey we
wanted to invite you to join us from the
early Thanksgiving on November 22nd
beginning around 2:00 p.m. please bring
your favorite dish and reserve by next
week and then it would propose three
answers for example the first answer
would be telecine second answer would be
will be there and the third answer is
sorry we won't be able to make it now
this where do these three answer come
from those those are the beams now
there's an algorithm to actually figure
out the diversity as well of the beams
so that you don't end up with very
similar answers so there's an algorithm
that like a heuristic that make these
beams a little bit more diverse and then
they pick the best three to present to
you
okay any question yeah I have a question
here
yeah there's no guarantees so the
question is how do I guarantee that the
the beam would terminate an end now
there's no guarantee it can go on
forever the indeed there are certain
cases like that if you don't train the
model very well now but if you train the
model well with with very good accuracy
then the model usually terminates highly
see any cases that it don't terminate it
doesn't terminate yeah but there are
some corner cases that it will do funny
things but you you can stop the model
after like a thousand or hundred or
something like that so that you make
sure that the model doesn't do that
doesn't go on crazy right I have a
question here
that's very interesting yeah it just
comes out because there's a lot of
emails and if you invite someone there's
more than one person and it might be it
learns about Thanksgiving it just mean
inviting the whole family things like
that yeah
it just learned from statistics yeah or
maybe that something like that yeah okay
okay oh in industry algorithm so the
question is do I do any post processing
to correct the grammar of the beams in
this algorithm we did not have to do it
yeah okay I have another question
so okay so the question how contextual
so I would say we don't have any user
embedding in this so it's pretty general
the input would be the previous emails
and the output would be the prediction
the reply that's all we have so it sees
a context which is the threat sofa okay
did I answer your question okay yeah we
you can catch me up after the talk yeah
oh yeah it ran down too so yeah slow
question oh oh I see
so the question is there's some some
emails are not relevant for a smart
apply maybe they've too long or you
should not reply or something like that
so in fact we have two algorithms so one
hour with them this is to say yes or no
to reply right and then after it passes
the threshold there's an algorithm to
run to produce the threshold so it's a
combine of two our rhythms that are
actually I presented earlier yeah I have
to get going but you can get back to the
question so there's a lot of a more
interesting stuff coming along okay so
so what's a big picture so far so the
big picture is that we have an i NN
encoder that it's all the input and then
we have an iron and decoder the trying
to predict one token at a time in the
output now everything else force is the
same way so you can use stochastic when
you sent to train the algorithm and then
you you do beam search decoding usually
you do app in search of up 3 and then
you should be able to find good food
good beam with the highest probability
now someone in the audience brought up
the issue that we use fixed length
representation so just before you you
make a prediction
the
Japan the hm and the white thing right
before you go to the Dakota okay
that is the fixed-line representation
and you can think of it as like it's a
vector that capture all everything in
the in the input right it could be a
thousand words or could be five words
and you use a fixed length
representation for a variable length
input which is kind of not so nice so we
want to to fix that issue so there's an
algorithm coming along and it's actually
invented at a at University of Montreal
you're sure he's here so the idea is to
use an attention so how does an
attention work so in principle what you
want is something like this every time
before you make a prediction let's say
you predict the world am you kind of won
a loop again at all the hidden state so
far you want to look at all what you see
in the input software okay now say when
you do fine you also want to see all the
all the hidden state of the input sofa
and and on now how do you do that in as
a program so well you can do this so you
H of M you predict a vector C let's say
that vector is the same dimension with
all the H okay
so if the your H of one each dimension
of 100 then C also have a dimension of
100 okay and then you take C and then
you do dot product dot product with all
the H okay and then you have
coefficients a 0 a 1 blah blah blah to a
to the N okay and those are scalars okay
and then after you have those scalars
you compute something called the beta
which is basically I stop max of all the
Alpha right so 2q compute that you take
the exponent bi is an exponential our AI
divided by the sum of Exponential's okay
okay and then you take those bi and then
multiply by H by
and then you take the weighted average
and then you take the sum and then you
send it to add additional signal to
predict the war and and then you keep
going with that right so in the next
step you also predict another C and then
you take that C to compute the dot
product you compute the B the a and then
you can compute the B you can take the B
you do the weighted average and then you
send it to the next time to send it to
the prediction and then you use
stochastic when you send to Train
everything okay
and this autumn is implemented in
tensorflow okay so how how into table
what is going on here so let's suppose
that you want to use this for
translation so in translation you wanna
for example the input would be hi how
are you and the output is Ola combos
paths or something like that okay and
then when you put it the first word you
want Ola to correspond to the world hi
okay because there's an one-to-one
mapping between the word high and Ola so
if you use the attention model the
beta's that you learn will put a strong
wait for the words Ola for the world
high and then it has a smaller wait for
all the stuff and then if you keep going
then when you say Como's then it will
focus on how and etc okay so it moves
that coefficient it put a strong
emphasis on the relevant world and
especially for translation it's
extremely useful because you know the
one-to-one mapping between the input and
output any question so far this is
definitely very complicated yeah I have
a question
all right now the beta other day and be
alone so I don't I don't
and so the question is how do I deal
with languages where the order them like
reverse for example English to Chinese
Japanese right so some of the verbs get
moved and things like that well I didn't
I did not have cold air be they are
learned so by virtue of learning they
will figure out what beta to put right
to wait the input and those are computer
basically computed migrated set right so
they just keep on learning okay I have a
questionnaire okay yeah so the question
is are they any work on putting
attention in the output yeah I think I
think you can do that I'm not too
familiar with any work in here but I
think it's possible to do it I think
some people explore something like that
yeah any question
oh I have a question another question
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so so the question
is less about because right now the
world hi is capitalized at the first
character it doesn't mean I'm using two
n or n vocabulary size so in practice
you we should do some normalization if
you have a small data set what you
should do is you normalize the tax so
high will be like lowercase and etc now
if you have a huge data set doesn't
matter we just learn okay yeah
I have a question there right yeah so it
so the question is in a sense it's
capture the the positional information
in the import yeah I agree I have a
question there a pattern punctuation ah
so the question is what do I do with
punctuation well they are in right now
I just present the algorithm as if it's
a very simple implementation like the
very basic but one thing that you can do
is you you before you train the
algorithm you put a space between the
world and the punctuation so that you do
some that is that step is called
tokenization or normalization in
language processing so you can use any
like a stanford NLP package or something
like that to normalize your text so that
is easy to train now if you have
infinite data then if you just learn
itself okay so I should get going
because there's a lot of other
interesting stuff okay so it turns out
that the the basic implementation but if
you want to get good results and if you
have big data sets so one thing that you
can do is to make the network deep and
one way to make deep is is in the
following way
so you stack your your recurrent network
on top of each other right so you know
like in the first sequence of sequence
paper we use a network of four but
people are gradually increasing to like
six
I and so on right now and they getting
better and better result like in image
net if you make a network people you
also get better results okay so i if you
wanna train sequin to sequins with
attention then do a couple years ago
when we like many laps working on this
problem were behind the state-of-the-art
but right now in translation many
translation tasks basically this model
our audio already achieved
state-of-the-art without in a lot of
these the pomt datasets so to train this
model so number one is that as i said
you might end up with a lot of
vocabulary our vocal vocabulary issues
so what Barack Obama will be this an
unknown right Hillary Clinton and season
unknown now you you might use something
like what segments right so you segment
the words out for example Barack Obama
would be bar and drag and etc or you can
use all the smart algorithms for example
word character split you can split words
that have unknown to be in two
characters and then you treat the meta
character there's some work at Stanford
and they prove that it works very well
so that's one way to do it you know tip
number two is that you you when you
train this algorithm because you when
you do back propagation or forward
propagation you multiply you essentially
multiply a matrix many many times so you
have explosion of function value or or
the gradient or implosion as well now
one thing that you can do is you click
the grade in a certain value right so
you say that if the gradient magnitude
of the gradient is larger than 10 set it
to ten okay then tip number three is to
use giu or in our work we use a long
short term memory okay so I want to
revisit this long short-term memory
business a little bit okay so what's the
long short-term memory so in
use an iron cell basically you can
catenate your input and your the the
hidden state and then you multiply by
some theta and then you apply with some
activation function let's say that's a
hyperbolic tangent okay now that's the
simple function for n n now in lsdm you
basically you multiply the input and
hash by a huge big matrix let's call
that theta that theta is four times
bigger than the theta I said in the iron
and cell and then you're going to take
that Z okay that coming out you split it
into four blocks its block you can
compute the gates and then you you use
the the value of a something called like
the cell and then you keep adding the
newly computed computed values to the
cell so there's this apart here that I
say that the integral of C is that what
it does is basically it keep a hidden
state where it keep adding information
to it so it doesn't multiply information
but it's keep adding information you
don't need to know a lot of this if you
want to just apply a SDM because it's
already implemented intensive law any
questions so far
okay so in terms of applications you can
use this thing to do
summarization so I've seen I started
seeing work in some radiation pretty
exciting you can do image captioning so
and the input in that case would just be
a representation of an image coming out
from vgg or coming out for google net
and etc and then you send it to the I
end and and we do the decoding for you
or you can use it for speech recognition
or transcription or you can use it for
QA so to the next part of the project
the top and we'll talk a little bit
about speech recognition
okay so well in speech recognition the
input could be maybe
waveforms right and then an output could
be some words you know hi how's it well
one thing that you can do is you drop
your input into Windows that's the green
box is there and then you crop a lot of
them and then you send a lot of them to
an iron and then you convert it into MFC
see before you send to Ana MFC see or
spectrogram or something like that okay
and then you use the algorithm that I
said earlier and then with attention and
then you do the transcription you
predict one word at a time in the output
now the problem with this algorithm is
that in turn when it comes to speech you
end up with a lot of input right you can
end up with thousands and thousand steps
so back propagating in time even with
attention can be difficult now one thing
that you can do is basically you do some
kind of a pyramid to map the input so
you if you do enough layers you can
divide your input into a factor of eight
or sixteen if you do enough layers right
and then you produce the output so we we
work in on an implementation where the
output is actually characters like like
the in the by - squawk where they have
the ctc now I have to say that the
strength of this algorithm is that you
actually have an implicit language model
in the output so when I say I when I
have the word how is actually
conditioned on hi
and stop before right and including the
input so there's an implicit language
model already but the problem with this
is that actually you have to wait until
the end of the input to do the coding so
the decoding has to be done offline okay
so if you use this for voice search it
might not be too nice because people
want to see the some some output right
away okay so in that case there's an
algorithm that can use it
do it in an online fashion
block-by-block now also I have to
mention that in translation this hour
the sequence sequence a wit attention
works great
it's a among the stay of the art but
when it comes to speech it doesn't work
as well as the CDC at least in published
results we're not as good as CDC which
is whatever what Adam talked earlier or
some of the hmm DNN hybrid which is
which is the most Wylie speech system
currently so I want to pause there and
then I can take questions any questions
I have a question at the back yeah yeah
yeah
Oh so how does the book in translation
well in translation what we do is
basically we have pairs of sentences so
for example hi how are you and then hola
como estas right and then we have pairs
of sentences like this and then we just
feed it into the turns out into the
sequence two sequences attention at
every step we again we're going to
predict one word at a time but before we
make a prediction the model has the
attention so it actually see the the
input once more before it makes a
prediction that's how it works
now what is can you repeat okay what is
the issue with with a model again please
yeah
I see well I I can't quite follow the
question but let's take it offline
is that okay yeah yeah and then we can
do some paper okay together
I have a question yeah yeah yeah okay so
the model I did the inbox thing that I
presented it was on in English but
there's no limitation in the model in
terms of language so let's suppose that
you in your inbox that you sometimes you
write in English and sometimes you you
write in in Vietnamese or sometimes you
write it in Spanish whatever and you
personalize by user embedding that I
would say that it will just learn your
behavior and then we will basically
predict the world that you want you make
you but make sure that your your output
bank vocabulary is large enough so that
it covers not only the English words but
also the Spanish word and etc like
Vietnamese and so on so your vocabulary
gonna be not going to be 20,000 it's
going to be like a hundred thousand
because you have more choices and then
you have to change your model on on
those examples yeah it's a matter of the
training data that's all okay I have a
questionnaire yeah
yeah yeah I saw the question is that in
the case of voice search right now you
have to wait at the end to make a
prediction is there any otherwise yeah
yeah the answer yes you can make a
prediction block by block so you can
actually figure out like an algorithm a
simple algorithm to actually segment the
speech and then make a prediction and
then take the prediction and feed it it
as input at the next block so you can
keep going like that so you in theory
you can actually do online decoding but
but I'm saying that the work on you can
do online decoding but that work is
currently work in progress how about
that okay I have a question there yeah
over here so we have some input email
and then some output email where export
written emails reply and then you can
just strain it that way yeah yeah okay I
have a couple questions
yeah yeah the question is that in speech
recognition the CDC seems to be a very
nice framework because it match it laser
like a monotonic increase Minh in the
output and the input but let CTC make
this independent assumption it doesn't
have a language model in it
maybe that's the the sequence of
sequence I can address this oh yeah I
think that's a great idea
maybe we should write a paper together
okay I think I think I haven't seen it
but I think that's a very good idea
question
I say okay great so so the question is
that is there because right now we
predict one step at a time is there any
way to actually look globally at the
output and maybe use some kind of
reinforcement learning to adjust the
output and the answer is yes so there's
a recently a recent paper at Facebook
who I think sequence level training or
something like that where they don't
optimize for one step at time but they
predict they look at the globally and
then they try to improve world at a rate
or they try to improve blue score or
things like that for translation and it
seems to be making some improvement in
the metrics that they care about now if
you show it to humans though people
still prefer the output from this model
so some of the metrics that we use in
translation and so on might not be what
the metrics that we optimize and the
next step prediction seem to be what
people like a lot in translation yeah so
so the question is can we add the GaN
loss like it again lost yeah I think
that's a great idea yeah I have a
question here yeah yeah
change yeah yeah
so let's suppose that you type the first
ha hola then you can actually start the
beam from there so the question is is
there any way to incorporate user input
so I say yeah it let's suppose that you
wanna you say hola sorry
hi how are you right and then as soon as
the person type hola
that actually restrict your beam so you
can actually condition your beam on the
first world Ola and your beam will be
better yeah I think that's a good idea
I have a question oh so how much data
did we use so in translation for example
we use the several several WMT coppices
Cobra and the W empty copper I usually
have tens of millions of seven pairs of
tendencies something like that and every
every sentence have like 20 words on
average twenty thirty words on average I
can't remember but that's something like
that order of magnitude
yeah yeah I have a question there I
can't really hear also how's it compared
to Google search auto-completion I
honestly I don't know what to use
underneath a Google search
auto-completion but if I were if they
you if I think they should use something
like this because it's okay I have still
lots of interesting stuff coming along
so okay okay so what's a big picture so
the big picture is so far I talked about
sequin to sequence learning and
yesterday Andrew was talking about most
of the big trends in deep learning and
it
talking about the second trend was
basically doing end-to-end deep learning
so you can characterize sequence of
sequence learning as an 2n deep learning
as well now so the framework is very
general so it should work from a lot of
NLP related tasks because a lot of them
you would have input sequence and output
sequence in our NLP it could be input
would be some text and output would be
some you know passing trees that's also
possible but it works great when you
have a lot of data now when you don't
have enough data then maybe you want to
consider dividing your problems into
smaller components and then creating
your sequin to sequence in the sub
components and then merge them okay now
if you don't have a lot of data but you
have a lot of related tasks then it's
also possible to actually merge all
these tasks by combining the data and
then have an indicator bit to say this
is translation this is summarization
this is email reply and then change only
and that should improve your your output
to now this basically conclude the parts
about sequence sequence and then the
next part I'm going to apply sequence to
sequence in a big picture of the active
on ongoing work in neural nets for NLP
so if you have any questions you you can
ask now I take maybe two questions
because I think I running out of time so
I have a question yeah
also the question is does the modem
handle emoji I don't know but it's emoji
is like a piece of text to write so you
can just like feed it into as another
extra token if you make them if you make
your vocabulary 200,000 then you should
be able to cover emoji as well yeah I
have a question also if you have new
data coming in so should I return the
model where you I think towards the end
we lower the learning rate so if you add
new data it just it will not make a lot
of good updates so usually we make you
you can add new data increase the
learning rate and then continue to Train
yeah that should work okay so I already
took two questions let's keep going so
so this is an active area that actually
is a very exciting which is in the area
of automatic unite so you can think that
maybe the set up would be can you read a
Wikipedia page and then answer a
question or can you read a book and
answer your question now you in theory
you can use sequin to sequence with
attention and then to do this task so
it's going to look like this you're
going to read the book right one token a
time and with the book then treat a
question and then you're going to use
the attention to look at all the pages
and then you make a prediction of the
tokens right so so that cut up that's
kind of sometimes you do we do answer
this question that way sometimes we
don't have knowledge about the fact so
we actually read the book again to
answer the fact but a lot of the time if
you ask me is Barack Obama the president
of the United States I would say yes
because it's already in my memory so
maybe it's better to actually akhmet the
iron with some kind of memory
okay so that it will not to do this look
back again right it's kind of annoying
look back again so there's an active
area of this research
I'm not a definite expert but I'm very
aware so I can place you in the right
context here so work in this area would
be memory networks by Western and folks
at Facebook
there will be new rotating machines that
deepmind dynamic memory networks would
be a richer soldier presented yesterday
and then stuck augmented iron ends by
Facebook again and etc now well let's
list so I want to show you a like
high-level what is this augmented memory
means okay so let's think about the
attention so the attention looked like
this
so you and in the end coder you're going
to look at at some input okay and then
you have a controller which is your H
variable and then you keep updating very
high variable but along the side you're
gonna write down into memory your h1 h2
h3 and etc right you store it into a
memory
clear-rite and in the decoder what
you're going to do is you gonna continue
continue producing some output right are
you going to update your controller G
but you're going to read from memory
your H okay right so that so so again so
in the import you write to memory in and
then in the output you read from memory
now now let's let's try to be a little
bit more general and the general would
be at any point in time you can read and
write right you have a controller and
you can read and write read and write
all the time now to do that you you have
to follow in architectures you have some
memory bank big memory back ok and then
you you can use the right you can decide
to write some information into it from
by a combination of the memory bank in
the previous step and the hidden
variable in the previous step and then
you also read into the hidden state to
and then you could make an amount update
and then
you can keep going forever like that so
this concept is called an N with
augmented memory okay is that is that
somewhat clear any question you have a
question the question is when you read
do you read the entire memory bank a lot
of these algorithms are actually soft
attention so yes it will look the entire
memory you can actually predict where to
look right and then read that only that
block now with the problem with that is
you end up with very it's not
differentiable anymore
right because this the thing that you
don't read don't contribute to the
gradient so it's going to be hard to
train but you can use to reinforce and
so on to train it so there's a reason
our paper reinforcement learning new row
Turing machines but actually so there's
something like this right not exactly
but it will deal with discrete actions
okay any question no question Wow okay
so the another extension that a lot of
people talk about is using an N with
augmented operations so you want to
augment the neural network with some
kind of operations like addition
subtraction multiplication the sine
function etc lot of love functions so to
motivate you you can think about Q and I
can fall into this for example histor
context the building was constructed in
the year 2000 and then it was in later
all people say oh it was then destroyed
in the year 2010 and then the question
would be how long it the building
survived and the answer would be ten
years now how would you answer this
question where you say 2010 subtract two
thousand ten years now neural nets if
you can train with a lot example it can
do that too you can learn too
subtract numbers and things like that it
requires a lot of data to do so all
right so maybe is better to augment them
with functions like addition and
subtraction right so the way you can do
it is that the neural network will read
all the token so far and we'll push the
numbers into a stack and then you get
the more the neural net is augmented by
a subtraction and a addition function
and these two phone and then you assign
these a probability for these two
functions so green the more duck does
mean the higher probability okay so you
aside to probability and these two you
compute the weighted average of the
values coming out of these two function
and then you take that and then you pop
it and you push it into the stack in the
next step and then in the next step you
will call the addition and subtraction
again and etc that's the principle of
something called neural programmers or
new neural programmer interpreters so
there are two papers last year from
Google brain and nygma was talking about
this so so that's that's some of the
related work in the area of augmenting
recurrent networks with with operations
with memory etc now what's a big picture
ok so the big picture I want to revisit
and I say so what I've talked to today
is sequin to sequence learning and it's
an end-to-end deep learning task so it's
one of the big trends happening in
natural language it's very general so
you can use if you have a lot and a lot
of supervised data it's a very
supervised learning algorithm so if you
have a lot of data it should work well
but if you don't have enough supervised
data then you consider dividing your
problem and then training different in
different components or you can train
jointly in an multitask settings and
people also train it jointly with auto
encoder namely to read the input
sentence and then predict the output
sentence again and that's also and then
you train jointly with all the tasks and
works as well if you if you go home and
then you want to make impact at your
work tomorrow then so far that that's so
far so good that that can make some
impact now if you want to do some
research and I think like things with
memory operation operation augmentation
are some of the exciting areas but but
it seems like still work in progress but
I would expect a lot of advances in this
area in the near future so so you if you
want to know more you can take a look at
pre-solar block you talk about attention
and of my augmented recurrent networks I
also wrote some tutorials pretty simple
this the sequin to sequence with
attention for translation is implemented
intensive flow so you can download and
you can use you can actually download
tensor flow and train it what I said
today
now this there's a lot of work going on
in this area not on many of these are
not mine so I so as you can see you can
even read the world just means how many
papers come along in this this area so I
can pause there and I have five minutes
to answer questions I have a question
there yeah
yeah
I see okay can you speak to the
microphone because I can't hear very
well add a microphone and then I think
people can hear that as well when you're
treating a Q&A network so you're taking
the example of training from a book to
answer questions yeah so if let's say
Harry Potter who was Harry Potter's
father now there could be many books
that have a character Harry so he has a
context resolution issue which is which
Harry should I answer the question for
ya how do you solve the context context
problem in your training this kind of
Q&A type Network I think that's a great
question so I think one thing is that
you can always personalize for example
you know that the guy when I talk about
you can have a representation for the
user and then you know that when he say
Harry his because he actually been
reading a lot of books about Harry
Potter so it's more likely to be Harry
Potter but I think with the hour time I
said I just want to make sure that it's
as simple as possible so the father if
you do the juicer has to ask the
question Harry Potter
rather than Harry but I'm saying if you
represent user vectors and then you
inject more additional knowledge about
the users about the context into as
additional token in the input of the net
the net can figure it out by itself yes
so that's one way to do it yeah okay I
have a question yeah you did some work
on Doc to Vic yeah do you have an idea
what the state of the art in
generalizing were two veggies to more
than one word oh I see
I think skip thoughts are interested in
directions here so dr. that is one way
but skip thought so that the idea of
skip thoughts was
Ruslan salakhutdinov with author on this
a his idea is basically using sequence
to sequence to predict the next sentence
so the input would be the current
sentence the output we would be the the
the the previous sentence all connect
sentence and then you can train a model
like that if the model is called skip
four and I have heard a lot of good
things about skip thoughts where you can
take the embedding at the end and then
you can do document classification and
things like that and it works very well
so that's that's probably one place that
you can you know can go my colleague at
Google is also working on something
called auto encoder so he instead of
predicting the next sentence he predict
the current sentence so trying to repeat
the current sentence and and that's kind
of work well too yeah yeah see what was
your thoughts on how to solve the common
sense reasoning problem Oh common sense
I'm deeply interested in common sense
but I gotta say I have no idea I think
maybe you can do something like I think
common sense is about a lot of first of
all there's a lot of knowledge about the
world that is not captured in text right
for example gravity and things like that
so maybe you really need to actually
combine a lot of morality that's that's
one way to think about it all the way
all the thing is do you make sure that
unsupervised learning work that's
another approach but I think this
digital research area I think I'm just
making guesses right now is there a good
way to have sent all these rules and you
know using some soft yes yes so the
question is how do you represent
Dru's so so if you think about this
network the neural programmer network
that it actually augmented by addition
and and subtraction then these are rules
right you can augment it with a table of
proofs and then ask the network to
actually attend into the truth table
people have looked
to this direction so that's one way to
do it okay saying basically argument is
to do some logical reasoning yeah yeah
yeah hey okay great talk yeah thank you
um are is there like a practical rule of
thumb for how many sequence pairs you
need to train such a model successfully
yes a is there are there any tips to
reduce how many pairs you need if you
don't I said okay so usually the bigger
data set the better but like the corpus
that people train this on translation
for example English to German it's only
about about 3 5 million pairs of
sentences or something like that so
that's kind of small 3 million right and
still people are able to make it to the
state of the art so that's that's pretty
encouraging now if you don't even don't
have a lot of data that I would say
things like pre-trained your work
vectors with language models or a word
to vac right that's that's one area that
you have a lot of parameters you can pre
train your model with some kind of
language model and then you reduce the
sub max that's another area that you
have a lot of parameters or use drop out
in the input embed in or drop out some
random word in the input sentence so
those things can improve the regular
radiation when you don't have a lot of
data okay yeah thank you okay yeah
thank you all so we'll reconvene at 6
o'clock for yoshua bengio
closing keynote